Hi I'm Toby and welcome back to another
video. Today I'd like to show you through
some of the early works of Isaac Newton.
These are very important contributions
to science and mathematics made while
Newton was quarantined at home during
the Great Plague of London. This was a
plague that went from 1665 to 1666, it
was spread by fleas and killed around a
hundred thousand people over the course
of 18 months. Newton had been studying at
Cambridge University and had just
obtained his degree in 1665 when the
university had to close as a precaution
against the plague. So Newton returned
home to Woolsthorpe Manor and over the
next two years there developed his
theories on calculus, optics and
gravitation. It is at this home where the
now famous apple tree is located. 1666
was Newton's Year of Wonders, he was
aged 23 at the time and he later said
that "in those days I was in the prime of
my age for invention and minded
mathematics and philosophy more than at
any time since". In this video I would
just like to focus on the work Newton
did during this time on the topic of
calculus and these pages are printouts
from the Cambridge University digital
library so the links for you to see the
originals yourself will be in the
description. This first document written
by Newton and dated October 1666 has
come to be called the 1666 Tract on
Fluxions. It is the first collection of
Newton's ideas on calculus. It is dated
in a different ink so this date could
have been added later on and there was
quite a rivalry between Newton and
Leibniz over who first described
calculus but regardless this document is
a collection of Newton's ideas since
1665 which can also be seen scattered
through his
earlier notebooks. It says to resolve
problems by motion these following
propositions are sufficient. He then lays
out a bunch of propositions and does
some examples. To Newton calculus was all
about motion and he was trying to
understand motion because the physics
problems he was also working on required
some kind of mathematical base such as
for gravitation. Neither Newton nor Leibniz were the first to completely come
up with calculus
they were both building upon the work
done by earlier mathematicians such as
Descartes. Let's work through this
demonstration here ourselves to see what
was going on. We're going to think about
the motion of a moving particle so at
one moment in time we could describe the
position of the particle with an x and a
y. These coordinates Newton would later
go on to call fluents
as they are flowing quantities. What
we want to know is how we would describe
this particle after a small period of
time. So if it has moved to here we would
describe its X position as being X plus
some new quantity and likewise in the Y
direction. To find how much it has moved
we would find the velocity of the
particle and multiply it by the small
change in time.
Newton refers to velocities in two
directions as being P and Q and he uses
O to denote a very small infinitesimal
change in time, so in the X direction we
would write this as P times O. O is not
equal to zero but it is very small so
after this change in time our X has gone
to X plus PO and our Y has gone to y
plus QO.
Instead of using P and Q Newton would
later go on to use X dot and Y dot as
the velocities and he would call these
the fluxions but that would have to wait
until a 1671 rewrite of this work. We can
see it in Newton's notes here he says "if
the described lines be X and Y in one
moment they will be X + PO and Y + QO in
the next. Newton then does a demonstration
where the relation between lines X and Y
is X cubed minus A B X plus A cubed
minus D Y squared equals zero. He says "I
may substitute X plus PO and Y + QO into
the places of X + Y." To expand something
like this he would have used the
binomial expansion theorem which he also
had a hand in developing. I will denote
these zeros here with a line through
them to make sure that they aren't
confused with these O's in here which
are not equal to zero.
Newton then writes out the result of
this expansion and he says that since we
know X cubed minus ADX plus A cubed
minus D Y squared was zero we can find
those terms in our expansion and cancel
them out and then he writes the result
of doing that. The next step is to divide
every term by O and were able to do
that since O is never actually equal to
zero and this is what we get. Newton then
says "also those terms are infinitely
little in which O is, therefore omitting
them there rests" and he gives the
solution. So if we cancel all of our
terms with an O in it as
being so small that they're not going to
contribute then we get the same solution
that Newton gets and it is our time
derivative of what we started with.
Remember that this is a derivative with
respect to time so it's like we had
differentiated this implicitly. X cubed
has become 3X squared times P which is
dx/dt. That is exactly what you would get
differentiating this and taking into
account that X and Y are functions of T.
This technique was a little
controversial because O is treated both
as being not zero and close enough to
zero to cancel out and nowadays we use
the notation of limits to make it more
rigorous. We would say that in the limit
of O going towards zero this term would
go towards zero. Now this whole
demonstration here was actually a
demonstration of proposition seven so
why don't we have a look back at
proposition seven to see what it was.
Proposition seven starts here and it
talks about "having an equation
expressing the relation between two or
more lines X,Y and Z and the relation of
their velocities P, Q and R may be found
by putting all the terms on one side of
the equation so that they are equal to
nothing and first multiply each term by
how many times P over X as X have
dimensions in the terms." Let's work
through what he's doing here. We're going
to start with the same equation that we
had before and we'll find its derivative
this way which is the same as saying the
relation of the velocities. So we times
each term by P over X for how many
dimensions of X it has so for example
this first term has three dimensions of
X so we will do X cubed times three
times P/X. The second term has one dimension of X.
The third and fourth terms have zero
dimensions of X so we times it by
zero times P over X which is the same as
multiplying it by zero so I'm not going
to write it down. He says that "secondly,
multiply each term by how many times Q
over Y as Y has dimension in it." So we do
the same thing now for Y. The first three
terms have zero dimension of Y so they
would be multiplied by zero but this
last term has two dimensions of Y so he
would times it by two times Q over Y. If
you had a third variable you would keep
going.
He says the sum of all of these products
shall be equal to nothing, yep so it's
equal to 0, and the equation gives the
relation of the velocities. So if we tidy
this equation up this X will cancel with
one of the X's up there and we will get
3X squared times P. These X's here will
cancel we'll get A B P. One of the Y's
will cancel we'll get minus 2 D Y Q
equals to zero and indeed this is the
time derivative of what we started with.
It was a quicker method than the one
we just did before but it's the same
result. I find that really awesome that
we were able to actually follow along
with Newton as he's doing some
derivatives. We can see at the end
here that he gives us a general form for
doing this. Later in the document he goes
on to apply these theorems to resolving
of problems you can see here he's
drawing tangents to crooked lines and
over here, problem five is to find the
nature of the crooked line whose area is
expressed by any given equation.
That is the nature of the area being
given to find the nature of the crooked
line whose area it is. All this talk
of area might remind you of integration
and Newton does go on to really talk
about the link between differentiation
and integration and finding the area
beneath a curve.
He seems aware that these two things are
inverses and that is the fundamental
theorem of calculus. This is another
document written by Newton but at a
later time and I just wanted to show it
to you because it shows that he does
later go on to use the terminology
fluxions where instead of using P and Q
for the velocities he uses X dot and Y
dot but the rest of the examples here
are the same. Fluxions were kind of
central to the whole Leibniz-Newton
controversy and in fact the last
document I would like to show you is a
letter in Latin that Newton wrote to
Leibniz via another middle man called
Henry Oldenburg and this was dated the
24th of October 1676
and in it Newton explains fluxions but
actually conceals his words in code
because he was so suspicious of Leibniz.
Around here he says "I cannot proceed
with the explanation of the fluxions now,
I have preferred to conceal it thus" and
then he puts this random string of
numbers and letters and it looks a bit
like a Bitcoin address but actually it's
an enciphered phrase and this phrase here
defines the relationship between the
fluent and fluxion.
Now what he did to get this, was he took
the phrase in Latin saying "given an
equation that consists of any number of
flowing quantities to find the flexions
and vice-versa" and he counted the
frequency of each letter and ordered
them alphabetically. If there were three
or more
of a letter then he would put a number
in front so it looks like there were six
A's and nine N's. Even if Leibniz could
decode this, the phrase doesn't seem to
show much, although it must have given
Newton some kind of security over the
idea. The fact he could put it down on
paper and make a claim in this fight
about his ideas being stolen. This issue
of ownership became so complicated
because Newton's work on fluxions and
calculus and many other things wasn't
published until a long time after he
wrote it. Even Leibniz's work wasn't
published straight away. I thought
this little document here would be a
nice insight into the relationship
between the two men. So that's been a
look at some of Newton's original work
even as a math student I don't think I
had really seen much of his original
thinking so I hope you found this video
a little bit interesting. You can go to
the links in the description to the
Cambridge University digital library to
see these documents as well as many more
about Newton. This video was made
possible by my viewers who support me on
patreon so if you'd like to help me
continue making videos like this then
please consider supporting me there too.
It's patreon.com/Tibees.
Thank you to my current patrons and a
special mention to today's Patron Cats
of the Day, Ghandalf the Gray and Beau.